8h51es bienvenue vous êtes dans la
matinale weekend sur télé on vous
souhaite une très très belle journée
tout de suite l'invité politique de
Claude askkolovic Claude vous recevez ce
matin François Baayou François baayrou
s'il est un européen c'est vous des
millions de Britanniques pétitionnent
actuellement au Royaume-Uni pour qu'on
revote là-bas son les nôtres les
pro-européens les vôtres en tout cas
est-ce que vous avez de la sympathie
pour eux ou est-ce que vous trouvez leur
démarche finalement peu démocratique
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour eux et
je partage leur tristesse et
ce sentiment de tristesse c'est un
sentiment qu'on éprouve aussi en France
j'ai été frappé vendredi le jour d'après
au moment des résultats auquels
visiblement les Français s'attendaient
pas j'ai été frappé de voir combien de
gens se sentaient blessés mais il y a
quelque chose de plus inquiétant encore
pour la Grande-Bretagne vous avez vu
toutes les fractures qui sont en train
de naître à cause de de ce tremblement
de terre uneè pas être a et les écossais
avec londr mais il y en a une qui est
Terri terrible c'est que les jeunes ont
voté à 75 % pour demeurer européens et
ce sont les générations beaucoup plus
âgé plus de 60 65 ans qui ont elles
choisi de revenir à l'isolement
britannique et quand un peuple vote
contre ses
enfants contre les forces vives les plus
jeunes de son pays alors il y a là un
très très mauvais et très inquiétant
signal je trouve que s'il y a une
fracture qui est euh particulièrement
blessante pour l'avenir de la
Grande-Bretagne c'est celle-là et vous
avez entendu sur votre antenne il y a il
y a quelques minutes tous ces jeunes qui
disent mais euh de quel droit on nous
enlève ça mais François Baayou de quel
droit des gens parce qu'ils sont plus
jeunes plus éduqué plus européens
whatever comme diraient les Anglais
peuvent s'abstraire du destin commun la
démocratie c'est qu'une voix de
prolétaire isolationniste de l'AD se
vaut une voix de jeunes londoniens ceci
est tout à fait vrai et heureusement
mais il faut ajouter une chose c'est que
la démocratie est au risque quand la
quand la démagogie prend les commandes
le risque qu'on est en train de vivre là
c'est un risque qu'on a connu très bien
dans l'histoire anglaise alors qu'il y
avait la montée de Hitler il y a eu des
élections dans lesquelles la victoire
s'est jouée sur le fait du
désarmement vous voyez Churchill s'est
battu tout seul contre contre cette
vague mais dans les années 30 vous voyez
la majorité du peuple britannique
entraîné par des démagogues qui vont
vers le désarmement ce qui fait que
quand Hitler va évidemment de
venir réaliser l'agression qu'il portait
en lui la Grande-Bretagne va avoir le
plus grand mal à se battre donc la plus
vieille démocratie du monde n'est pas
immune est-ce que nous sommes immunes
nous d'un vote qui vous paraîtrait
aberrant à la présidentielle de l'an
prochain par exemple s'agit pas que de
l'Europe alors l'élection présidentielle
c'est autre chose l'élection
présidentielle a sans doute beaucoup de
faut mais elle a une vertu en tout cas
je le crois je l'espère elle a une vertu
c'est que le peuple
juge de la
responsabilité du caractère de celle ou
de celui qu'il va porter à sa tête il le
peuple sent si c'est un capitaine si
c'est quelqu'un de solide si c'est
quelqu'un à qui on peut faire
confiance ou bien si au contraire c'est
un aventurier ou une aventurière
et je crois que c'est la principale
vertu de l'élection présidentielle alors
naturellement les hommes ou les femmes
sont pas toujours à la hauteur de cette
attente j'espère que cette fois-ci ils
vont l'être parce que ce qui se joue est
tellement important et tellement grave
et tellement lourde conséquence que
cette prise de conscience des citoyens
va j'espère aider ceux qui sont des
hommes d'État ou en tout cas des hommes
civiques dans leur comportement hommes
et femmes civiques dans leur
comportement vous étiez hier avec un
homme pour lequel vous avez voté en 2012
et donccun vous l' procher donc François
Hollande il y a test de caractère et de
présidence pour François Hollande
maintenant après le brexit presque plus
qu'après les attentats alors c'est
dernière chance enfin à supposer qu'il y
ait une dernière chance possible parce
que je pense que la situation le
jugement des Français sur François
Hollande est très sévère et probablement
à mes yeux à juste titre mais là alors
parlons de responsabilité du président
mainten là on a besoin d'hommes d'État
c'est-à-dire de gens qui ont une vision
et qui sont capables d'entraîner le
peuple des citoyens et leurs partenaires
européens et c'est sur ce point que j'ai
des doutes la la situation qui a été
créée par l'espèce de comment on peut
dire ça de de retrait de la France
depuis des années vous voyez bien
anguela Merkel elle jouait avec les
Anglais hein c'était alors maintenant
cela n'est plus possible et donc il y a
pour François Hollande une
exigence d'être enfin au moment où nous
sommes à la hauteur de cette histoire et
la hauteur de cette histoire c'est quoi
premièrement il faut et je crois qu'il a
l'intention de le faire il faut que se
règle rapidement la question de la
situation de la Grande-Bretagne qui a
choisi de sortir et donc que vous avez
vu qu'hier et c'est un geste que j'ai
trouvé élégant le commissaire anglais à
Bruxelles a démissionné en disant je
peux plus être commissaire mon peuple a
voté non mais monsieur Jun a dit qu'il
est prêt à en nommer un autre mais
sérieux bon mais il va en nommer un
autre parce qu'il faut bien bah il faut
bien expédier les affaires courantes
mais la voix de la Grande-Bretagne par
ses représentants le commissaire ou les
parlementaires européens ne pourra plus
du tout être la même et la place des
fonctionnaires britanniques au sein de
la Commission de Bruxelles ne pourra
plus être re la même les fonctionnaires
britanniques ils avaient bâti depuis
très longtemps une une présence clé au
sein des ils avaient fait ça très
habilement il avveit sélectionné de très
bons fonctionnaires il les avait mis
dans les places clés maintenant il faut
que tout ça se rle il a raison il y a
une deuxième chose qui est nécessaire
c'est qu'on dise enfin aux Français de
la part du gouvernement français du
président français qu'on dise enfin aux
français où allait l'Union européenne
dans laquelle nous sommes embarqués on
ne peut pas continuer à avoir une Union
européenne qui apparaisse comme
totalement opaque aux yeux des Français
et que le Président de la
République disent enfin ce que l'Union
européenne est en train de délibérer ce
qu'elle va décider ce qui se passe avec
le traité transatlantique quelles sont
les les harmonisations par exemple
fiscales ou sociales que nous pouvons
avoir au sein désormais d'une Europe
plus compacte en tout cas on peut
l'espérer il nous reste une minute c'est
rien pour le destin n on avait donné
beaucoup à David Cameron lors d'un
sommet européen en décembre dernier
tropop trop comment puis-je faire
confiance moi citoyens européens ou
français dans ces dirigeants européens
qui étaient prêt à tout donner à Cameron
et qui aujourd'hui expliquent qu'ils
vont refonder l'Europe de manière plus
cohérente de qui se moque-t-on sur ce
planl alors je voudrais qu'ils disent
qu'ils vont la refonder de manière
cohérente je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
l'intention d'un certain nombre de
dirigeants européens et c'est là où on a
besoin de la voix d'un président
français de responsables français qui se
fassent entendre l'Europe est un projet
français c'est simplement nous l'avons
laissé dévoyer nous l'avons laissé
entrer dans une espèce de de monde pour
initier on a maintenant besoin d'en
faire un espace dans lequel citoyennes
citoyens jeunes et plus âgés
retrouveront leur choix c'est-à-dire la
la compréhension et l'influence sur leur
choix France Irlande
franceirlande j'espère que la France
gagnera mais vous savez l'Irlande va se
trouver aussi je ne parle pas là du
football je parle
de non dans une situation clé est très
difficile puisque le vote signifie qu'on
va rétablir des frontières à l'intérieur
de l'île qu'entre Belfast et Dublin
faudra montrer un passeport et avoir des
postes frontières et ça c'est une chose
qui va être très
lourde consquence économique et civique
merci François baayot d'avoir été avec
nous heureusement qu'il est pour la
France ce sera affreux sinon ouais vous
nous avez pas dit combien votre
pronostic François baayot pour
aujourd'hui de depuis les matchs que
j'ai vu ces jours-ci franchement je ne
fais plus de pronostic parce que je
trouve que
c'est le référendum est très décevant
mais l'euro est extrêmement décevant les
le jeu que nous avons vu ces derniers
jours n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
pouvait espérer maintenant j'espère
qu'il va l'atre cet après-midi merci
beaucoup en tout cas et puis merci à
Claude ascolov merci Françis d'avoir été
avec nous on va parler des Bleus
évidemment tout de suite mais aussi des
élections en Espagne et à Notre-Dame des
land